hey what you guys doing nothing we're
just watching some merge so you want to
join us
I only watch real anime
one up asking up
we're talking but pillow in your locker
bro this is some pillow this is an
authentic dango imported from Japan or
more accurately neat one
okay you wanna pass me the thumb go then
don't touch my daughter
bro I'm actually starting to think that
the ethnic manga is better than the
anime will actually roll it's pronounced
manga yo man I really like your Miyazaki
posters thanks bro
well actually guys it's pronounced me
lucky the cool again bro I've been
watching welcome to the NHK man
it's sick the guy is like hiki something
whoa he's something it's people coming
people call me bro sick my mom ate some
tiramisu awesome
well actually guys it's pronounced to
brawl Hermes was Italian
[ __ ] you
my man sick shot of anime yeah yeah I
actually just finished watching the
archetype but I was gonna start bleeding
for really good things
oh yeah
could I get you anything else no I'm
good thanks you get together with my
stop Ron fished a guy's Russian
you
hasn't asked
man I've actually thought about taking
up meditations that heard only good
things you know that sounds pretty cool
man bro meditation is so cliche I only
practice meditation what's that that's
when you meditate while singing songs
from chinmaya anime
whoo man it's so fun lumping on us
alright alright that's enough I'll go
get the next guy alright guys it's my
turn I'll show you how it's done come on
because such amateurs man
yo it's here that it's here here what's
here
finally my fatherly I'm a man
finally I'm a man